bei der es zu schlagen hallo mein name
ist khan herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren folge murphy bot letzte folge
murphy wort kam ultra gut bei uns
angemeldet alle judoka macht das noch
mal
deswegen mache ich doch mal wir befinden
uns wieder schön in sky wo wir mit dem
motherboard lagern können das ist ja
noch mal zur erklärung ich verlinke euch
übrigens das alte wieder mal kurz ihr da
habe ich auch schon erklärt ich erklärt
euch jetzt aber einfach auch mal
jackpots klickt ihr jetzt drauf ich
spiele beim murphy bord geht es darum
dass das ein skype kontaktes den werden
können den habe ich schon gerettet und
den können wir dann die sachen tragen
wie what if kong crafter rostock und
dann sagte er mir wie ich aussehen würde
wie wenn nicht ein
die schau mal wie es aussehen würde wenn
ich ein hund wäre what if konkrete worte
dort ihr seht ihr übrigens auch den
alten chat verlauf mit den er als devil
und wir haben kräfte als das bin doch
nicht ich das sieht aus wie ein
kinderriegel kind was auf der verpackung
ist ich habe jetzt einfach mal gefragt
what if kong crafter boss kinderriegel
also ich weiß nicht ob da jetzt als
sennfeld man könnte halt echt so drücken
eigentlich also wenn ich wenn ich nicht
so psycho mäßig schach und würde alter
das ist ja ultra der des der der murphy
board entwickelt sich wie sonst was ich
weiß nicht ob so daherkommt weil das
viele youtuber jetzt machen und deswegen
so viele leute da sachen irgendwie nie
einreichen muss man daher gar nichts
maximal thema zu mir dass er einfach
seine sachen von google bezieht also die
bilder das heißt er googelt jetzt
beispielsweise congo after und kinder
riegel und packt dann irgendwie
gesichter zusammen aber murphy bot das
kannst du ultra gut falls solche
übrigens fragt wieso ich so fertig
aussehen kommt dass ich mittlerweile
auch in jedem dritten video nach
erklärungen warum ich so fertig habe
letzte nacht
fünf stunden geschlafen ist halb vier
ich muss ihn verstehen schreibt also das
ist der grund warum ich nur fünf stunden
geschlafen habe also ich hab gerade
klausur geschrieben ist es gerade 12 uhr
ich hab von 10 bis 12 uhr klausur
geschrieben und letzten acht noch
irgendwie von 12 bis 4 uhr gelernt dann
um 38 auf gestanden
deswegen bin ich ein bisschen fällt da
zähle ich meine damit die linke mit
videoarbeiten assistent teilte man ihr
konntet mir unter die letzte folge
kommentare schreiben was ich mal
eingeben soll als kommentare zum
beispiel what if kontrakt aber aus der
und der oder das sind dass unser motto
für dortmund da wird auch sehr oft
geschrieben wird es konkreter ich hab
das wort vergessen broadcom crafter was
katja krása wüste das ist ja diese sehr
umstrittene halb schon nackt dass auch
ich werde nicht mehr dk es sieht so aus
wie ne wie eine wie ein vierjähriges
kleines grundschul mädchen mit
operierten brüsten das ist doch ein
dicker das ist doch ich habe letztens
gehört diese katja soll 19 sein dicker
die ist ein jahr jünger als ich bitte
werdet nicht so wie die bitte die man
natürlich jeder soll irgendwie machen
was er will aber ich halte überhaupt
nichts von schönheits op een also wenn
man sich operieren lässt wenn man da von
vorteil hat irgendwie dadurch kann
wenn man arm gebrochen hat und ich hab
ich habe ja keine ahnung aber die das
ist doch das ist einfach nur ich hatte
also ich habe da keine worte für vor
allem nicht wie ich als katja glaser
visser aussehen hier was ist wenn ich
das noch anders rum eingeben also was
katja krawitz award.com crafter weil
dann kommt der theoretische dieses kong
crafter bild was der sonst mal als
erstes am eingang alles klassiker so
sieht also katja aus wenn sie in meinem
körper wäre das ist auf jeden fall ultra
comedy am neues bild von mir übrigens ne
das ist ja ultra fresh dieses bild wieso
habe ich das noch nie gesehen behauptet
für das ipad also was wäre also der map
report ist richtig schnell geworden
dj kommen wir sind nimmt er dann nicht
ein hund und eine katze anstatt
irgendwie so einen katzen kosten
what if concept davos murphy wird mich
auch mal interessieren weil wie würde
ich denn aussehen wenn ich merke wäre
alles klar
ja soll ich dazu sagen
frage die sich wahrscheinlich jeder
gerade stellt weil der murphy bot jahr
sondern so ein bisschen mit der clever
bot ist ist ermotti murphy boxclever bot
also wenn der murphy und clever wartet
einer person wäre jeden tag nur noch das
hochladen
dass das ist clever bot und murphy also
bei allem respekt sondern da sehe ich
jetzt tatsächlich keinen murphy hier
irgendwo drin
viele sagen wenn man das nicht
unglaublich herzlich bin deswegen gebe
ich jetzt einfach mal einen what if kong
crafter was pretty also wenn ich
wirklich hübsch wäre ich weiß nicht ob
er das mit adjektiven machen kann
da ist einfach mein gemeint man ein
gesicht gibt über gegen die wand hinaus
dass das muss aber noch lernen dass das
ein bisschen abschneidet jene einige
wollte noch wissen was passiert wenn ich
ein geber what if konkreter boss luca
also ich meine ich bin einerseits von
crafter andererseits aber auch luca und
ich denke er bezieht jetzt ein bild von
crafter von google und ein bild was
kommen wenn man luca eingibt deswegen
kommt jetzt gerade als ist das lokal
handy ich habe ich keine ahnung wieder
im kader aussieht aber ich glaube so
könnte er aussehen oder also dass das
bin ich als luca was ist denn mein
kontrakt akon crafter ist ein paar
sekunden später alles klar
einfach wenn ein kompletter congo after
wäre würde ich einfach noch hässlicher
aussehen tatsächlich an dieser stelle
würde ich aber auch sagen freunde das
wird wirklich am meisten gefragt wurde
ist dass ich mich mal mit katja kramer
wissen und was passiert wenn ich ein
gebe wenn ich selber ich selber bin ich
als jetzt gut gefunden wenn er
beispielsweise ein eines bild mit mir
mit einem anderen bild von mir verbunden
hätte das herzige resultat sind nämlich
einfach nur blöd aus als die weitere
coole ideen habt ich weiß ihr hattet und
am letzten video schon so viele tausend
kommentare geschrieben was ich eingeben
soll schreibt sie die kommentare und
wartet andere coole ideen hoch dann sehe
ich die wenn ich eine neue folge
aufnehme sonst würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen falls euch gefallen hat
und ihr mehr vom murphy bord haben wollt
und dann sehen wir uns in einem nächsten
video wieder und zwar morgen in einer
ruhm tour wollte eine ruhm tour also